okay good evening I'm I'm Bradley Graham
I'm co-owner of politics and frozen
along with my wife listen Muscatine and
on behalf of the entire staff on behalf
of the entire staff at the bookstore
welcome thank you very much for coming
you know back in February 2016 when the
Republican primary field still was was
pretty crowded John Nichols wrote an
article for the Nation magazine
headlined President Trump it could
happen at the time of course the
scenario seemed quite a stretch
well now we're living it and John has
taken the time in in his new book
Horsemen of the Trump cop ellipse I was
just talking to John about how tricky
that where it is and I was determined
not to trip over it so anyway in his new
book Horsemen of the trumpet Coppola -
uh - he's taking the time to sketch out
several a dozen of the top players in
the Trump administration in doing so he
draws on decades of political reporting
experience he's been a national
correspondent for newspapers in Toledo
and Pittsburgh and currently writes not
only for the nation but also for the
progressive
and in these times he lives in Madison
Wisconsin where he's an editor as well
at the Capitol times you may also have
seen him on TV where he frequently
appears as a commentator and he's
authored ten or co-authored ten or
twelve books so you don't really sit
still too much do you John no now lots
of things about the Trump administration
have proven to be to say the least
rather unsettled so far and indeed in
the time since John finished his new
book in June and and its publication now
several of the senior advisors profiled
in it have exited
among them Steve Bannon Reince Priebus
Sean Spicer and Sebastien Gorka but many
more who will surely have considerable
considerable influence over the trump
presidency remain in the cabinet or in
other government offices and John
examines their connections and special
interests and the impact they're likely
to have needless needless to say but
I'll say it anyway
John is a highly critical of and
strongly opposed to Trump he calls for
an all-out resistance that identifies
quote all the wrongdoers all the
collaborators and conspirators within
and around the Trump presidency and and
calls for holding them to account and he
intends his book as a step in that
direction so we should be in for some
rather spirited discussion this evening
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming John Nichols all right people
say it with me Trump pocalypse see now
look how well they did you know I had no
idea when I set out to write this book
and I you know like I'm not I'm not one
of those serious people that puts a lot
of effort into the writing I think of
the title first right and and I had no
idea when I set out to write this book
that the title would be such a difficult
thing but I've done about 20 radio and
TV interviews so far and some of the
smartest people in America have
struggled with the term Trump pocalypse
I'm gonna make it very simple for you a
trump pocalypse is what happens if the
people that Donald Trump empowers get to
take things to the place where they
would like to take things and a Trump
eclipse is averted if a we know who they
are which would require us to have a
media that covered politics I'm not sure
rather than personalities number one we
know who they are and number two we know
how to resist
they seek to do and that's the point of
this book and let me tell you I know
we're all supposed to be depressed and
scared writing this book caused me to
understand a couple of things first off
anyone can be a member of a cabinet I
will guarantee you if I took the first
five rows I'd have a better cabinet than
Donald Trump house and if I took some of
the people in the back it would really
be great because it's the it's the later
riders who are out there doing good
works and I just want to start out
quickly by saying thank you to politics
and prose which is a wonderful
independent bookstore that stands strong
it's gone through the some of the
downturns of the book industry and now
as people have come back to the book
back to the printed page this store is a
model for the whole country and I just
want to thank Brad and everybody for
having me here I want to thank c-span
which is with us tonight and never gave
up on the book c-span book TV and all of
the work they do really does open up
this dialogue from the left and the
right brings everybody in and I have to
tell you in this book I learned you know
when I like was analyzing some of these
cabinet picks in that you know what I'd
do I'd watch morning journal and I'd
listen to the calls on both sides
because it really gives you a
perspective you know where the power
base is for many of these members of the
Trump cabinet and his advisors and
allies are and many of them I will tell
you are stronger than Trump this is an
important thing to understand many of
them come with historic power bases
rooted in their wealth in their
connections in their long term
ideological journeys that make them
people Donald Trump cannot fire let us
all just say the name Jeff Sessions no I
mean you people ever he's like oh what's
Donald Trump gonna do I mean when's he
gonna get rid of Jeff Sessions he isn't
going to get rid of Jeff Sessions unless
he's watching tonight and he's
embarrassed by the fact that we revealed
this but the truth of the matter is that
Jeff Sessions has a power base
rooted in the South but also rooted in
people who are militantly anti-immigrant
and people who have played the race card
again and again in our politics this is
a small portion of our society but it is
a portion that was essential to donald
trump's base so essential that after the
tragedy and the horror of
charlottesville donald trump struggled
to call out the people that any decent
american president would have said have
no place no place whatsoever in the
deciding of our politics or what
monuments we put up or how our
communities are organized and so Jeff
Sessions will remain but he won't remain
for good reasons I wanted as I mentioned
one other things we're introducing here
someplace in the back is my my dear
friend Ben wiggler there he is and then
this is hey I'm always in the room with
people who are more important than me
and which is essentially every one of
you but but in this case if you watched
the fight over the health care bill the
heroes of the fight over the health care
bill and over trying to get rid of what
is called Obamacare the heroes of that
fight were people with disabilities who
came from across this country and stayed
for days even weeks sometimes slept in
the streets say they suffered great pain
it was incredibly difficult for them and
yet they came because it was a matter of
life and death for them and their
resistance made it possible to prevent
this administration and its allies in
Congress from achieving one of their
greatest goals and a person who was out
there because he one of the leading
figures in moveon.org
who was out there every night with them
and also with other people who had come
across the country to assemble and
petition for the redress of grievances
as our Constitution makes it clear that
we can was Benwick ler if you saw videos
of the moment when it was announced that
the Senate had rejected the legislation
had rejected what McConnell had put
forward you see this very young handsome
guy jumping up and down and punching the
air and cheering and that was Ben
wiggler is right in the back
so let me tell you about this book for a
few minutes and then we're gonna take a
lot of questions tonight because c-span
is here and we love c-span for a variety
of reasons but number one it's your
chance all to be on television and as we
know if you're on television a little
bit you could be President of the United
States so let's let's begin now with why
did I write this book because wouldn't
it have been the the right thing to do
indeed it was a almost two years ago I
was covering Donald Trump as he
campaigned for president it became clear
to me that for a variety of reasons in
our politics as it has has structured
out that there was a possibility that
Donald Trump could become president
United States it was clear to me very
early on that he would be the Republican
nominee because he figured out the
Republican Party which isn't that hard
the Republican Party is a bunch of very
rich people who exploit the fears of
people who are not as rich as they are
and what Donald Trump did was come in
the middle of them and say to the people
who were fearful who were in difficult
situations who were scared sometimes who
were really mean people whatever he said
to him those guys up there the elites
they've been lying to don't vote for
their candidates and the Republican base
said you bet let's worth you we don't
like them either and so suddenly there
was a rejection of the Republican
Party's elites and then Donald Trump
turned around and he used a very similar
strategy in running in November which
was to say to a broader grouping of
Americans look don't trust the people
that you have trusted up to this point
they've been lying to you they've been
letting you down and that that would get
him a long way now remember just to
point out here he did lose he got 46% of
the vote which is a better part more
than a point less than Mitt Romney got
losing in 2012 he lost the popular vote
of the country by almost three million
votes he 54% of Americans didn't vote
for Donald Trump to be president United
States if we lived in most countries on
the planet
he would have he'd be back with a TV
show right now
and I think everyone would be happier
including Donald Trump but because of
the vulnerabilities in our system he
became president one of the things that
I realized as I was covering him during
the 2016 campaign is that he's a great
showman he's fabulous at getting in
front of a crowd of people and riling
them up because he does something that
modern movies and modern television does
but most of our modern candidates don't
realize you can do and that is be a bad
boy right say something that's just a
little bit risque a little bit beyond
what you're supposed to say and people
who have grown horribly bored with
politics who see politics is the most
routinized predictable thing around saw
well here's this guy who says things
you're not supposed to say and that was
very very appealing he figured that out
and that got him through a long way but
the other thing that I recognized very
early on is that Donald Trump knows
nothing about governing I mean I don't
say that to me you know I mean this guy
knows absolutely nothing about governing
and unlike Ben whittler or a lot of
other people he hasn't spent his entire
life thinking about what if he became
president of the United States you know
the famous the rock star Patti Smith
said that when she became a rock star
when people wanted to interview her she
was ready because she had spent 20 years
in front of the mirror interviewing
herself right she really thought I'm
going to be a rock star and I'm gonna be
ready for it Donald Trump didn't do that
he didn't know people he didn't have the
connections he didn't understand the
process he was manifestly unprepared to
be President of the United States and so
what I knew from the very beginning was
that when he became president United
Sates if that did happen and I'm not
gonna tell you I predicted it I said it
could happen and then I thought no they
come on right I was let down but one
thing I was absolutely certain of from
the start was that Donald Trump would be
defined not by what he did by but what
the people he appointed to key positions
did
that his presidency would not be about
him it would be about how he distributed
the power of the presidency and this is
a very big deal because everyone in this
room says no no you're not right mr.
nickles every single night all that
television ever does is show me every
single thing that Donald Trump did that
day I have memorized every one of his
tweets I have watched every one of this
but you know we see him verbatim 24/7
that's not governing that's not running
a country that's that's The Apprentice
that's a TV show and he's good at that
but he knows nothing about how to
assemble a government and so I was sure
even before the election that the real
story of this administration would be
who this guy who knew nothing about
doing it put into positions of power and
a brief segue here the presidency wasn't
always like this anybody here know how
many members of the cabinet George
Washington had yes sir no hey we got a
winner there you were very good in the
game brother but we have a winner who
said four or five he's exactly right it
was four or five depending on how you
count John Adams the vice president but
we actually know the member we know the
names of the members of George
Washington's cabinet they may they do
plays on Broadway about them Hamilton
right and Jefferson these are big deal
people we remember Donald Trump he
struggled when he was when they had
Betsy DeVos at the White House when he
was like announcing he struggled to
remember which job he was appointing her
to now I'm not kidding I mean this guy
there's more government than he knows
what to do with and and it has expanded
to become so Imperial as Arthur
Schlesinger jr. suggested that a
president has the ability to put people
in charge of huge aspects of our future
education transportation war and peace
these are definitional positions and
Donald Trump didn't have any idea who he
was going to pick remember when you
like T's and Romney maybe I'll make you
Secretary of State maybe I won't and you
know and he's like he was bouncy he
could he was struggling because they
literally had people coming in and
presenting themselves to him to try and
lobby for the position that's not how
it's supposed to work you're supposed to
come to a position of power with at
least a few ideas about what you want to
do and who you want to put into key
positions he didn't have that and so he
went in case after case with the loudest
Yeller
now that's an old Woody Guthrie term our
Stetson Kennedy actually Stetson Kennedy
was a singer and a writer down in
Florida in the 1930s and 1940s friend of
Woody Guthrie Guthrie popularized this
term loudest Yeller Stetson Kennedy said
I want to be the loudest Yeller right I
want to be the one people notice well
when the loudest yellers came in to meet
with Donald Trump he's like yeah I like
you you make a lot of noise and so who
did he put in charge of education Betsy
DeVos Betsy DeVos has been the loudest
Yeller against public education as we
know it and as we would like it to be
for the better part of 20 years no one
would ever have paid any attention to
her whatsoever except for the fact that
she's rich and in America if you're rich
you can be President of the United
States or you can be Secretary of
Education but you're not that because
you know anything about it you're that
because you buy your way into it it was
summed up I have it right about all
these things in the book there's a when
when Betsy DeVos came before the Senate
committee that was constitutionally
bound to analyze whether she was
qualified to serve as Secretary of
Education literally to guide the future
of our children the best question that
that was many good questions came
through Maggie Hassan from up in Vermont
and other people are up in New Hampshire
I apologize asked terrific questions and
really got to the heart of the fact that
she didn't know about programs that were
central to what the Department of
Education does she literally was
ignorant about what were federal
programs and what were state programs it
was a trad
painful performance Betsy DeVos made me
feel sorry for her and I never thought
that was possible but she she got
through most of it just in this tragic
stumbling way until Bernie Sanders came
up and Bernie Sanders who actually
understands issues of economics and
class and wealth and poverty he just
looked at it for a long time and he said
mr. boss I got a question for you
if you hadn't given two hundred million
dollars you and your family two hundred
million dollars to Republican candidates
including some of the people in this
room here today and who are going to
decide your fate if you haven't given
two hundred million dollars do you think
there's any chance that you'd be sitting
here with this nomination and to her
immense credit and I really I give her I
give her a lot of do for this she didn't
say of course I would be I know
education top to bottom I'm I'm totally
qualified for this she said well it's
possible but even she knew this was
ridiculous and and the fact of the
matter is the fact of the matter is that
nominee after nominee after nominee for
key positions and also people who never
had to go through the confirmation
process but took those positions in a
point of posts who were given immense
power by Donald Trump literally the
power to decide the future of
communications in this country to decide
whether we have net neutrality to decide
how our television networks operate and
how they organize to decide how Wall
Street operates decide how its regulated
to decide fundamental questions of how a
military industrial complex what what
Dwight Eisenhower warned us about which
structure out in these times and then
you get to the fundamental questions of
how we deal with technology and all
sorts of other issues the people he
empowered we're capable of impressing
Donald Trump a man who knew nothing
about government and had thought very
very little about the future but they
were not ready to do the jobs they were
given and the fact of the matter is that
if the United States
it had done its job and gotten beyond
silly partisanship and silly ideology
and literally just done the job that the
Constitution requires them to do
there is simply no question that they
would have rejected Betsy give us they
would have said you cannot have this job
you you just can't you should not be in
this position they would have rejected
Scott Pruett at the Environmental
Protection Agency because they would
have said when he stood up there said oh
yeah I'm kind of mixed on climate change
I mean you know I'm working my way
through in this they would have known he
was lying to them because the fact of
the matter is Scott Pruett has been one
of the central climate deniers of our
age is a guy who regularly sues the
Environmental Protection Agency they
would have rejected him because it was
absurd to put him in that position
because it doesn't matter whether you're
a conservative or a liberal it doesn't
matter whether you're a Democrat or
Republican there should be a base line
of competence and a base line of respect
for the agency that you are in charge of
if you want to shut an agency down if
you want to dismantle it then you should
be elected to Congress and you should or
elected president you should work on
dismantling it but if you're given the
responsibility for making sure that the
water that our children drink is safe if
you're given the responsibility to
making sure that we are prepared to deal
with hurricanes which hit major cities
and leave the fourth largest city in the
United States under water then you
better understand the current science on
climate change and you better be ready
to establish climate resilient
infrastructure so that you don't end up
with more crises like the ones we're in
and Scott Pruett wasn't prepared for
this moment he should not have been put
in that position
I hope I make myself clear which brings
me to Rex Tillerson now Rex Tillerson is
one of the most dangerous group I write
about in the book are those who are
referred to as adults in the room you
know if somebody if anyone of you is
called an adult in the room run
screaming from that room right because
number one it's it is said that you've
been picked for a position by someone
who cannot be trusted given power by
that person and then you're supposed to
keep them under control with all due
respect I pick my daughter do a lot of
things and I give her power to do a lot
of things and sometimes she's under
control right but she doesn't control me
as much as she would like and the fact
of the matter is that Donald Trump gave
these people positions of immense power
but there's no adults in the room it's
an absurd construct it is a fantasy that
people have built up to try and make
themselves feel good Rex Tillerson was a
corporate CEO of a fossil fuel company
in an administration that doesn't take
climate change seriously that's not an
adult in the room that is an enabler for
somebody who's wrong
telling them that they can be wrong and
that they can do the wrong thing that's
not a healthy pick that's not a team of
rivals that's not the best and the
brightest this is an administration of
people who are there because Donald
Trump thought that they were smart
thought you know this is what a smart
person sounds like to Donald Trump and
but also because he wanted people he
knew would do what he wanted them to do
Donald Trump's not the kind of guy who's
saying yeah go out and run that thing
I'll come back and check with you in six
months and here's the tragedy of Rex
Tillerson he'll probably be the first
one to go the first big one to go with
all the respect I mean I know how
exciting Sebastien Gorka is but you know
please right I'm talking about people
with real power and ultimately people
who are doing a lot of stuff that we
aren't paying as much attention as we
should to Rex Tillerson probably the
first one
go because he was put in charge of the
Department of State a historic
department that has existed since the
founding of the Republic in the book I
talk about each of each of these
agencies each of these positions how
they developed why they exist the
Department of State exists as a
counterbalance to again what Eisenhower
referred to as the military-industrial
complex you wanted to have somebody
there who say no maybe we can talk our
way out of this thing maybe we don't
have to have a war maybe we can have
diplomacy maybe we can have aid maybe we
can relate to the rest of the world well
in this administration Rex Tillerson is
clearly not listened to he is clearly
not well regarded and he has chosen to
allow the Department of State to be
diminished dismantled and undermined in
ways that no Secretary of State in the
history of the country has ever done he
is a horrible steward of an essential
agency of our federal government and you
knew that from the committee hearing
because he was asked when he was before
the key committee where they were
deciding whether he should be Secretary
of State they said have you talked to
Donald Trump about you know like the
Middle East yeah well we didn't get
around to that
and we're like have you talked to him
about you know this problem or that
problem we didn't get around to that
he acknowledged to the committee he had
no idea he had no idea how he would
relate to Donald Trump as president
United States they should not have put
him in this position now if he had said
I'm gonna oppose Trump I'm gonna put me
in this position I'll slow him down I
won't let him do some of this stuff well
then I would have said yeah go for it
but this guy this guy wanted the job but
didn't have any idea of how he would do
it and he hasn't shown it since then and
so I had to be honest in this book I'm
pretty unsparing with a lot of folks I
acknowledge when people are smart Steve
Boehner was very very is very very smart
it's probably smartest man in the room
in fact weirdly enough in the Trump
administration Steve Bannon probably was
the adult in the room he reads
extensively he thinks about issues he's
he takes the title chief strategist
because he really is a strategist
and I disagreed with him on fundamental
issues on a ton of issues but he was a
guy who actually thought about a lot of
this stuff wasn't just bouncing from
moment to moment he's out of the
administration but I suspect he's more
influential now than he's ever been
because one of the things is people say
well Steve Bana went out so everything
must be cool right cuz Bana he was on
the cover and they had pictures of him
saying he was the real president well he
wasn't the real president he was there
at Donald Trump's behest remember but
the interesting thing is Steve Banta
really is smart he really is a
strategist Donald Trump went off the
rails in Charlottesville
all right in the aftermath of
Charlottesville he had a series of
statements that showed him to be someone
who should not be the president the
United States it's not an ideological
statement this is not a partisan
statement this is simply saying if you
can't after a bunch of neo Nazis and
fascists and supporters of the
Confederacy get in a fight with people
who don't like racism you can't have a
president who says yeah there's troubles
on both sides no no that's like that the
comic argument about you know like see
the eastern always criticized CNN that
said they'd had you know people from
both sides of an issue right and you say
well what about the great moments in
history like the Civil War would you
have somebody on both sides of slavery
well Donald Trump says yes
I mean he literally says yeah you know I
don't like fascists I don't like Nazis
but you know there's some very fine
people marching with him at that point
something big had to change something
big had to happen and so Steve Bannon
stepped out so ultimately did Sebastien
Gorka but don't think for a second that
their ideas stepped out the reason I
profiled them in the book and why I
don't mind who comes and goes to some
extent is because these are people that
Donald Trump embraced these are people
that he took lessons from and the truth
of the matter is Steven Miller is still
there and if you think that Steve Bannon
and Sebastien Gorka are scary I invite
you to go back and look at some videos
of Steven
this guy has moved on the hard right
since he was a young teenager in the
book I write about his journey and it's
it's horrifying in many ways because it
is it's such an example of someone who's
gone way to the fringe way to the fringe
on so many issues who somehow has ended
up in a position of power helping to
write Donald Trump's inaugural address
helping to do the Muslim ban apparently
giving advice as regards to Joe Arpaio
pardon and things like that you know
Donald Trump has empowered people to do
profound things many of them are doing
them in our name without our informed
consent as we speak but he has also
brought people around him who reinforced
his worst instincts and I'll close off
and go to your questions with just this
one counsel if you like Donald Trump I'm
delighted you're here and I'm delighted
you know I'm delighted you joined us and
and we'll have real dialogue and I think
that's that's that's superb because in
this country we ought to be able to do
that if you don't like Donald Trump if
you choose to resist Donald Trump you
must understand this Donald Trump is a
TV entertainer if all you do is resist
Donald Trump then you are resisting a TV
you're like flipping the channel on TV
you must understand who he is put in
positions of power you must understand
why they are there and what they will do
with those positions you have to expand
your focus if you don't do that then it
is very possible that people will say at
some point you know Donald Trump was a
total failure as president and then
someone will write a revisionist book a
couple years later and say I don't know
how much of a failure he was he dialed
down the struggle against climate change
at a critical point he prevented us from
looking at the future of technology and
the role that that our changing economy
will have in our lives because of
changes in technology because he just
has no vision in this regard he moved
money out of social welfare programs and
over to the military-industrial
flex that Eisenhower and others warned
us about Donald Trump changed our
country fundamentally issues that he
didn't do it the people he put in charge
of cabinet agencies and regulatory
agencies and all of these incredibly
influential incredibly powerful
positions did it and if we don't pay
attention to what word what they are
doing then shame on us shame on us
because ultimately Donald Trump cannot
bring the Trump pocalypse but the people
he has empowered can bring a Trump
pocalypse and the Trump pocalypse a word
I can pronounce the Trump eclipse isn't
all the scary bomb stuff that people
think about that's legitimate I don't
dismiss people thinking about who's got
their finger on what button but the
Trump pocalypse is a fundamental
restructuring of the United States in
ways that will make this country
unfamiliar not merely to us but to our
parent would have made it unfamiliar to
our parents our grandparents and
everyone who ever fought for a country
with liberty and justice for all
that's something that we need to avert
that's why we need to avert the Trump
pocalypse thank you now if I'm right
look at that I was supposed to go 30
minutes and you have 30 minutes for your
brilliant questions I like and we do ask
you to come to the mic if you can
because it's your best chance to be seen
on television
so in your book yes do you talk about
the Republican Senate
yeah that's enabled all of this oh my
and we are not related I did not put you
up to this question but I adore you for
for asking it
in fact I profile about 40 people in
this book
many of them are cabinet secretaries
many of them are White House hangers-on
many of them are members of the Trump
family who are sort of unidentifiable in
their role and completely ineffectual
with all due respect Ivanka Trump but
also I look at the Congress a lot
because I believe that Paul Ryan did
more to make Donald Trump president than
anyone else including Donald Trump
because everybody says oh Paul Ryan he
doesn't really like Donald Trump he
objects now and again every time that
Paul Ryan objects to Donald Trump he
says well I wouldn't have said it that
way which by the way is a horrible
thought right
yeah his objection is that Trump doesn't
spin things well enough but then he
would always say but if he's the nominee
of our party I will back him and so it
is Paul Ryan who expanded the definition
of Republican to include Donald Trump
and so understand he's the core of a
making Trump president but the core of
making Trump's presidency successful
without a doubt unquestionably is Mitch
McConnell and I will tell you that
Donald Trump is a very ungracious man
admittedly he did appoint McConnell's
you know wife secretary transportation
that's sort of nice but but I mean he's
kind of picking on Mitch now and I will
tell you nobody moved heaven and earth
in the way that Mitch McConnell did for
this guy and I am ashamed of our United
States Senate I'm genuinely ashamed of
it because I'll give you one quick thing
I recount in the book
just days before Scott Pruett was named
secretary or named administrator of the
department or of the Environmental
Protection Agency put in charge of a
very important you know aspect of our
government just days before he got that
job a judge in Oklahoma ordered the
release of
documents from his tenure as Attorney
General which had been sought by public
interest groups for months in some cases
years that revealed his interactions
with his ties to the fossil fuel
companies that as head of the EPA he was
supposed to rein in and oversee and
control this is incredibly important
information to the process Jeff Merkley
from Oregon Sheldon Whitehouse other US
senators went to the floor of the US
Senate and said can we just wait until
these documents are actually released
the order had come down they were
literally going to be released within
days and Mitch McConnell went to the
floor of the Senate and enforced
discipline and forced that nomination
through knowing knowing that if they had
waited just a few more days even
Republicans could not have avoided for
this guy it was atrocious governance and
in a shameful shameful disregard for his
oath of office his responsibilities you
know what's supposed to be shared
governance and I I don't even have to
tell you you know what he said to
Elizabeth Warren when she raised
essential fundamental issues about the
nomination of Jeff Sessions and I will
tell you this though before we let the
next person ask a question in my chapter
on Jeff Sessions I do find it
unimaginable that he's the Attorney
General the United States I open the
chapter with with just a line that that
kind of sums up the whole chapter what
can be said about Attorney General Jeff
Sessions that hasn't already been said
by doctor David Duke
first thanks for very kind words this is
Ben wiggler I've known him since he was
12 and he has it as as he has exceeded
expectations well thanks for for all
your friendship and mentorship since I
was a young teenager hopefully not like
Steven Miller in the healthcare fight we
could pressure Congress and members of
Congress are accountable to their
constituents it's more difficult with
cabinet agencies because they're not
directly elected and I'm thinking right
now about like net neutrality today's
the end of a critical comment period who
knows what's going to happen with those
comments what can we do as as citizens
and as Americans to try to fight against
and resist what these cabinet appointees
and other Trump appointees are doing
that's a terrific question and one of
the things I do in the book is I
actually I was on a radio show with a
wonderful woman she had read the book
which makes her different than a lot of
radio interviewers and and she she said
you know I read your book over the
weekend and it made me dramatically more
depressed and and I said well you didn't
get the point you know the point is to
empower you to to deal with these things
and so the first step of empowerment is
to know who these people are George
Washington could name all the members of
his cabinet it wasn't hard Donald Trump
struggles with it we've seen video of
him struggling to remember who's where
and most citizens because our media is
so presidential focused so personality
focus they don't begin to see what
happens in cabinet agencies and and also
in regulatory agencies like the FCC this
is a big deal too because it's also
about the change in our media
historically in the United States we had
daily newspapers around the country that
had Washington bureaus tremendous number
of those bureaus have closed as the
newspaper industry has contracted it
used to be that the reporters from the
Des Moines Register kept watch on the
Department of Agriculture the reporters
from the Detroit Free Press in the
Detroit News kept watch on the
Department of Labor
yet people from around the country who
brought specialized interests to
Washington and and kind of kept
reporting and then that was an early
warning system we've lost a lot of that
and so one of the things I do in the
book is highlight those who are doing
good reporting encourage people to
follow those who do look at all these
different agencies and all these
different positions and also the
activist groups that are watchdogging
and they're serious about it as well as
the members of Congress who are doing so
and I want to pay tribute here actually
something Sebastien Gorka who was the
president's advisor on counterterrorism
although anybody was an expert in
counterterrorism had doubts about you
know what where where he really got his
training or at least what he knew but
Sebastian gark I had had a incredibly
nefarious past it with ties to groups
that in Eastern Europe that had it by
the accounts of some people fascist or
neo-fascist history and it was really a
lot of dark stuff and one of the reasons
that Sebastian Gorka is out of the White
House today it isn't because members of
Congress by and large did their job it
isn't because Donald Trump you know God
got upset by it he is out of there
because of the date because of the
newspaper the forward the forward is a
Jewish American newspaper over a hundred
years old in New York City and when they
saw Sebastian Gorka wearing medals at an
event that were historic medals from
what they and they believed to be
neo-fascist groupings in Eastern Europe
they put reporters on the ground in
Eastern Europe to dig out the story to
talk to members of these groups to
really get to the bottom of it
that led congressman Jerry Nadler and
others to call for his removal and
really created the situation that led to
him exiting after charlottesville people
need to understand this if you don't
know who these people are
if you don't know their history if you
don't know your bet their background you
cannot possibly begin to hold them to
account
so the first duty of this book is to
help people to know who they are and to
understand that you can make your
decisions about them once once you're
there but then also I as I said I spent
a lot of time pointing people toward
groups that are working on these issues
and I do say one other thing as well
this morning I spent some time with
Ralph Nader who had read the book and
was very generous about it and Ralph
Nader who's always monitored these
cabinet agencies points out correctly
that it's not impeachment isn't just for
presidents anymore the impeachment power
exists for presidents vice presidents
and those they empower and so you can
hold these people to account and I'm not
saying you know wholesale go for
impeachment what I am saying is if there
are people who have lied to the Congress
if there are people who have
fundamentally failed in their duties use
that tool to hold them account censure
impeachment all the possible tools and
don't just focus all that energy on
Donald Trump spread it around because
there are people there are people who I
say this quite often in any room in this
administration that Donald Trump walks
into he is not the most scary person
Thank You Ben
hey as troublesome as as troublesome as
Trump is on so many levels shouldn't we
also be looking deeply at the deep flaws
within the Democratic Party which
enabled Trump in the first place and
which will enable more Trump's to arise
in the future you are a very wise
questioner again not related to me but
I'm glad you're here look I mean with
all due respect any any statement on
this begins with the line they lost to
Donald Trump you know that's a that's
not good that's not a healthy thing
because there's a guy who did not
present particularly well by the most
measures here's what I would say the
Democratic Party has people in it who
have mounted really bold and impressive
objections I think Elizabeth Warren has
done incredible job I think Al Franken
has risen to the level of being a member
of the Senate and I would say mention
the name of someone else who I write
about a lot in the book kirsten
gillibrand from New York State she voted
against more Trump cabinet picks and
nominees than any other member of the
Senate and she did so because she was
not afraid to stand in defense of
civilian control of the military and so
many of these people voted for these
generals who've been nominated for these
positions and senator children said hold
it the
you know the whole point of this thing
is that we're supposed to have civilians
in key positions as regards the military
because Eisenhower was right a military
industrial complex is a scary thing
many Democrats failed in that regard
there's no question the Democratic Party
is in desperate desperate need of a
reformation and I say that in the
religious sense all right you know a
genuine Reformation and but I will
extend for any question if I can to one
other thing I believe Donald Trump's
presidency is about the most hopeful
thing about Donald Trump's presidency
and all these people he's empowered in
all this stuff I think he is a warning
sign of the vulnerabilities in our
democracy and one of the vulnerabilities
is existence of an electoral college
that allows the loser of the popular
vote to become president that is absurd
but another of the vulnerabilities is
what we've allowed the cabinet system
and the federal government to become it
is so big and these cabinet agencies are
so powerful when I was writing the book
looking at their budgets looking at what
they control it's astounding and we've
created a situation where it is very
easy for people who should never be in
charge of so much of our governance to
take those positions so it's it's a
political vulnerability I agree with you
but it is also a structural
vulnerability that we really have to
revisit because with all due respect our
Secretary of Energy the guy who's in
charge of taking care of nuclear waste
is a guy who wanted to eliminate the
department but couldn't remember that
Rick Perry I'm sorry you could not if we
were doing a Broadway play we could not
make this up it would it would be too
absurd so vulnerabilities in the system
our Democratic Party has got to change
it is vulnerable it it and if they don't
change they run the risk of more Trump's
you are right maybe a trump who is a
little better presented but also we have
fundamental structural flaws that Trump
is helping us to see and that his
appointees are helping us to see again
though we will not address those
structural flaws unless we see this as
about more than one man more than just a
president of personality and I have a
lot of objections how the media covers
this administration because it's largely
about this one man unless we the people
can get beyond that we run the risk of
replacing Trump with someone who's a
little better
and we aren't a little better isn't
going to get us this is going to fix the
damage that is done over the next few
years on that in terms of the
traditional party framework it's very
very hard and I and I will answer your
question by saying there's a lot of
people behind you so I want to you know
do you don't know I'm not pushing you
away but I'm telling you that as we
speak and my friend Colin Robinson will
be thrilled by this I am working on a
book on the future of the Democratic
Party it'll be my next book and and I'm
pretty scathing in this book about the
Trump administration I will not spare
the Democratic Party I think the
Democratic Party has some wonderful
history and some wonderful people in it
but it has to become a smart party you
counter you counter lies and stupidity
and fantasy with facts and intelligence
and and courage and conviction and the
Democratic Party has to has to show a
lot more of that if they're going to
begin to challenge not just Trump but a
process that gave us Donald Trump
whoever is next
but yes hi there okay move it get to
that mic I know it's it's yeah excuse me
do your best
thank you that's exactly what I believe
mr. Trump is doing right now in a state
where there Senate legislature wanted
him to be assassinated this is an
uncouth public I have been upset I think
that the courage if you ever have
greatness thrust on you you're certainly
verbal and can manage the end of
representing your ideas well but he has
with courage and stamina and family
presence put himself at risk the reason
I think this happened is because we
allowed a debt structure in 2015 before
he announced his intention to run for
office to buy the very excellent basis
of index of the OS and OCD
Oh II CD our international debt to be
twenty two point five trillion mr. Trump
did go ahead he ran and in the course
mid-race had himself to borrow fifty
million dollars our failure once before
we in finance from finance allowed a
world to have credit available we would
not have had radical and to poverty nor
a trillion then a zillion times
computing ability possible in a short
period of time were it not for this form
of money being made possible for the
common man and when it's also security I
didn't have questions but two answers
for your Protege one is that the
agencies the SEC in the IRS for example
which are in need of reform do keep up
internal bulletins and monitor and have
working group correspondence with the
federal government about their own
thoughts and responsibilities and then
the second is that we must stop the
merger and acquisition table type of
impact on the common man it's
dehumanizing and it has changed work and
initiative and Catholic and I mean that
by that Universal yes reason for
participating in government and then
also you're wrong about the things that
you said not only is mr. Trump
courageous but he went in person that's
something availability is very radical
tweeting is horribly democratic the
second thing is Jeff Sessions while
everyone was talking about Ivanka brand
the and it's question ability he went
and identified 2.4 billion dollars of
fraud and Medicare he went about his job
like an Alabama Attorney General of high
moral standards the third point
Betsy DeVos give her one second is your
third point give her just a moment Betsy
DeVos sis you're implemented with the
Public Library System in four major
cities nationwide building a better
world
it was inordinately successful we're
trying to help people have literacy in
our country I'm going thank you for that
you've done a great job of presenting
there's more there's your contemptuous
of Senate Senate passed s eight the
digit act di GI T stands for delving
into the growth of the Internet of
Things the Senate is very wise and
capable and acting in its own time as
well as possible across a broad broad
range of things that there's a person
who disagrees with me and probably with
a good number of people in the room and
I think we have to conclude here I just
let some more people you got one last
thing to say but quick thing shot down a
missile an anti-ballistic missile so by
our defense demonstrated our safety I go
back to earth today after a threat by
the demonstration of American ability to
take down a ballistic missile now do you
be President
yeah I am president we are free people
you cannot police it free photos but
thank you for your good contribution I
just give her a round of applause
because it isn't easy no I will tell you
something it is not easy to stand up in
a room where maybe perhaps a lot of
people disagree with you and I will also
say that you know what she is what she
is trying to say what I think I won't
speak for her per se what I think she's
trying to do is say there are things
that that many Americans find in Donald
Trump's tenure they agree with that's
okay that's alright what I am saying is
to those who do disagree with this
presidency who do those who do object to
how its operating that you have as a
duty to be as courageous as she was when
she just stood up in this setting and
offered her views because the fact of
the matter is as long as we're talking
to
each other as long as we're debating and
stuff we're gonna get through this thing
Donald Trump is a blip in the history of
this country I promise you he's a
transition point what I'm concerned
about is whether he is a transition
point to something dramatically better a
ricochet out of it or is he a transition
point to a politics where we will have
variations on Donald Trump from here on
out that's what we will decide and with
all due respect to my friend I believe
that that we don't want more Donald
Trump's and I also am not satisfied with
our Senate but I respect her for asking
that question
my friend hi John let me just say on
behalf of all the people who are not in
line to ask questions I think there is
one thing that we can all agree with her
on and that is the fact that the
tweeting that we've seen since this
presidency started has in fact been
horribly Democratic with the emphasis on
horribly well can i address it for one
sec many people say to me you know look
we should not follow Donald Trump's
tweets anymore we shouldn't have them on
TV all the time or things like that I
strongly disagree this is an incredibly
powerful person we should watch what he
does we should listen to what he does if
we agree if you agree that's fine if you
disagree you should let make it known
all I'm saying is that's not enough it's
not enough to simply pay attention to
the man's tweets or his press
conferences or as rallies it is vital to
see what Scott Pruett is doing it is
vital to see what Elaine Chao is doing
it's vital to understand that barely a
week ago at that horrible press
conference where Donald Trump went off
the rails on Charlotte's ville he was
announcing changes to our federal
regulations our approach to these things
in which he was gutting Barack Obama's
executive order from 2015 to make sure
that US spending on infrastructure took
in the concerns about climate change and
storm surges and flooding and that that
Obama order was titled the federal law
risk management standard in Elaine Chao
and Donald Trump overturned that barely
two weeks ago and most Americans didn't
even know it I didn't affect it didn't
affect Houston they said that this is so
for the future but let me warn you that
what they did what they did was to say
we refuse to learn from what is
happening to this country that is
shameful and you can't let that occur in
the dark without people knowing about it
so I want to pay every attention to
trump but I also want to pay every
attention to everybody else makes us
work a little harder stamp later what's
your question sir so the this regulatory
capture piece that you're talking about
is huge I mean clearly these are the
people who will enable all that
invisible change but they in turn are
kind of being enabled to and you
mentioned Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
by a very compliant Congress and part of
why they get such a compliant Congress
is the gerrymandering and the
suppression that's going on so I you
know knowing your Wisconsin background
I'm wondering if you can can talk about
for example the Wisconsin Supreme Court
case on redistricting and maybe some of
the other institution you've had a lot
on the table then overlay that I will do
it very quickly yeah only because
there's a wonderful group of people
behind you in line there and so all I
would say is I'm not going to go into
the Wisconsin they'll just say look it
up we follow what's happening in
Wisconsin on the issue of gerrymandering
we could see the United States Supreme
Court finally address one of the core
democracy issues in this country which
is the fact that most of our
congressional races are non competitive
I will only focus on one thing a person
I write about a lot in the book and that
is Kris Kobach he is he is the guy that
the president has empowered to
essentially be giving advice and counsel
on voting rights election issues and a
host of matters all these things that
you're raising and the fact of the
matter is that I've cut I've covered
this Kobach character for years going
back to when he was working with the
American Legislative Exchange Council
and other groups on a host of what can
only be in my view
voter suppression initiatives and he is
the worst possible person to have in
charge of this stuff and we ought to
enly say that that we ought to be on top
of what he's doing every day and we
ought to be ready to resist it because
the answer to the question of could
Donald Trump get reelected it's not
merely about his policies and it is not
merely about economic issues that are
always in play it is also about the
quality of our democracy how healthy is
our democracy and I fear I fear that the
people he has put in charge of
overseeing and giving advice about how
we should organize our elections are
some of the worst players and some of
the most disrespectful players as
regards democracy in this country and so
that's why I write about Kobach but it's
also why I think we have to pay a lot of
attention to thank you for your good
question my friend could we take quick
if people can be quick I'll take a
question from each and then price
comments I like your thoughts about
first of all clarification there's just
as many millionaire Democrats as there
without advance so I think if you're in
a great place by being a journalist and
author and all is I think until we get
out of this simplistic mindset of it you
know fix the Democrats and fix the
Republicans the root of the issue will
not be addressed what he takes the route
that I think it goes back to the
Declaration of Independence where we
really never did overthrow the king boy
you are so right I think the analogy is
when I just we just changed it to have
the subservient role towards the
corporate entity yeah okay I apologize
and let me quickly say this woman got to
the heart of the matter and if you go
back and I write a lot about this in the
book when they establish the system of
checks and balances when they establish
separation of powers Congress was really
powerful in fact the president doesn't
have the ability to impeach the Congress
the Congress has the ability to impeach
the president this is big deal
we have thrown things so out of whack we
have created such an imperial presidency
in this country that it has created
tremendous dysfunction and one of the
reasons I wrote this book is to get
people thinking about whether they want
a presidency that is as powerful as this
one is Sir I think you got we're down to
those seconds I'll keep it simple and if
you do as good as her I mean we're out
of the park mister everything all right
where did Kellyanne Conway come from my
friend my friend Liz Winstead who's a
comedian was at the mini in Minnesota
State Fair and she tweeted apparently
they had a Kellyanne Conway's scarecrow
and the Scarecrow contra where they had
her inaugural thing and it was I don't
know if that was respectful or
disrespectful I'm not sure where I was
coming from but Kelly icon was a good
place to circle this around I'm glad to
answer other people's questions as we go
along as well we'll stick around and
sign some books and do that and I'm so
appreciative of all you'd be in here but
the answer to that question is really
interesting when I start the book with
Robert and Rebecca Mercer who are major
campaign donors and interestingly enough
yeah there you go
interestingly enough Robert and Rebecca
Mercer had two people that they really
get put a lot of resources into and gave
a lot of support to before the 2016
campaign one of them was Kelly Ann
Conway who was pollster and a person who
ran a super PAC and did all sorts things
very close to the Mercer's who are
incredibly right-wing tech billionaires
and the other was Steve Bannon and
amazingly enough after Donald Trump got
the Republican nomination and these very
wealthy people moved into position who
ended up running the Trump campaign and
I will just simply tell you that Kelly
about Conway is still Kelly economy
still in the white house she is still
very very influential and she and Ivanka
Trump in my view played an incredibly
significant role in the campaign one
that we should not forget and that is
when things came out about Donald Trump
that made I think virtually everyone
gasped the revelations about what he
said on the bus and some of this stuff
it was Kellyanne Conway who more than
anyone else stepped up and really stood
by him
and and defended him after that's that
key debate and I think she played a very
very critical role in making him
president the United States more than
more than is noted
she's now doesn't seem to have a lot of
influence in the White House but one
thing I will tell you about Donald Trump
and it's why if somebody quits there
comes or goes don't take it all that
seriously Donald Trump constantly
recirculates people he brings people
back into power people who you thought
were gone returned I'm I don't even rule
out that scarra Moochie could come back
and and I will tell you that in some
ways I missed the mooch but brothers and
sisters you have been an absolutely
tremendous audience
I think you've acquitted yourselves well
don't forget the Labor Day is coming up
and I really believe in renewing the
tradition of the Labor Day gift and I
just happen to think that that horsemen
of the Trump akka lips makes a fine
Labor Day gift thank you for being here
[Applause]